a six-month cbs news investigation has
uncovered new information about some of
the thousands of veterans who served at
a remote base after 9 11.
what we're learning is that female
service members who pass through the k2
base
are reporting high rates of reproductive
health issues including cancers
u.s troops there supported missions in
nearby afghanistan
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herrod shows us the female
vets health struggles
today catherine good morning to you tony
good morning based on our earlier
reporting the acting secretary of
defense chris miller drafted an
executive order
that would open the door to medical help
and financial relief
the need is especially acute for women
who served at the base
man i'm just trying to get through
pouring through her own medical
records former army intelligence analyst
elba barr
is trained to connect the dots there's
been something massive since 2013
every year medical wise while barr
deployed across the middle east in
africa
after 9 11 to track al qaeda there is no
question in her mind
the most toxic and dangerous place was
this former soviet air base in
uzbekistan known as k2
a jumping off point for classified
missions into afghanistan k2
was to me a base that should have never
been a base
hazards signs everywhere where your
hazards were
the 41 year old mother of two blames the
four months she spent at k2
for her chronic reproductive health
issues i had cervical issues
continue to having severe pain
endometriosis had to have a partial
hysterectomy
last year i had both of my ovaries
removed and they found
onset stage one cancer barr is one of
more than
200 female k2 vets who flooded this
facebook page
the nonprofit that tracks these cases
says 40 percent
self-report at least one miscarriage
eight percent
report breast or uterine cancers and 30
percent
report ovarian cancer or related issues
data that brought barr to tears
that's horrifying a cbs news
investigation
revealed soil saturated with jet fuel
oil and lubricants
radiation warnings as well as prior use
of chemical agents
defense department employee mike
lechleitner was involved in early
testing of the base
we learned that the soviets had had
a chemical weapons decontamination unit
adjacent to our camp these 2003 images
obtained by cbs news
showed the base was also a dumping
ground for used chemical weapons
equipment
this protective gear including face
masks to block chemical agents
was found within walking distance of
tent city where troops worked and slept
what was the impact of the cbs news
investigation
for you life-changing i've spent the
better part of 10 years
wondering am i going crazy and so
that's what see that's what it did it
validated all a decade's worth of issues
barr is now speaking candidly with her
children about her toxic exposure
i have no doubt i'm going to die young
catherine you're assuming that i'm not
i live on borrowed time 100 it's not a
matter
of if it's a matter of when
despite the data the va does not
recognize a link
between k2 and illness barr wants
leadership
to step up if you ask us we'll we'll do
it again
in a heartbeat and all we are asking for
is we upheld our end of the deal
and it's on the va and it's on the
department of the defense to hold up
theirs
the executive order was in its final
stages when the capital was overrun by
riders last week the k2 vets group is
hopeful
it will still get signed by president
trump though they are reaching out to
the biden team
in case there's no action before the
20th tony
and we'll hold up our end of the deal
which is to continue to shed light on
stories like this one catherine thank
you very much